lebanon's economic crisis has devalued
its currency and is hurting many in this
once middle-income country among them
Public School teachers who want better
pay
to get to work we need four dollars a
day
how are teachers going to survive
education is being disrupted for a
fourth year financial support from
International agencies like UNICEF has
so far prevented the service from a
total collapse but there's only so much
they can do
with the International Community UNICEF
has been providing support to the entire
education sector for many years and we
have intensified that support and
providing school books providing funds
for electricity for schools School funds
parent Council funds and trying to do
our best to keep the schools open we
urgently call on the government of
Lebanon to find the resources to be able
to pay the teachers a livable wage
public education is not the only sector
in crisis and dependent on support the
World Health Organization provides
medicines and pays hospital bills and
staff at Public Health institutions
while the world food program feeds a
third of the country's 6 million people
the Army too receives food donations and
cash assistance for its Soldiers the
list goes on Aid that came into Lebanon
in 2022 is more than the state budget so
if you just look alone at the aid that
came in through the UN programs it's
around a billion dollars that's the
state's budget for 2022 and this gives
you an idea of how much we've become
dependent on Aid in fact the Lebanese
economy is today mainly dependent on two
things eight and incoming transfers from
the diaspora
the dependence is expected to increase
as the political Elite fails to address
the financial crisis
since lebanon's Financial collapse in
2019 the International Community changed
the way it has been dealing with those
in power here it is no longer injecting
money without conditions and when it
does it channels funds through
institutions other than the state
sustained financial support is what
Lebanon needs to be able to respond to
the needs of its people but that means
reforms to the way it is governed and
that means politicians losing Authority
and control over the state and Society
[Music]